do you talk about building or you talk
about building relationships a lot at
work even when people whom you might not
like even with people who mean you don't
like have you always been this way or
did you also feel difficult also
difficulty in wanting to build
relationships with those people if the
latter what are the things that help you
to actually want to build relationships
with him things so when I was a young
seal
I was pretty typical young seal pretty
typical young man meaning I thought I
was invincible I thought I could beat
everyone in a fight cuz I didn't know
jiu-jitsu so you just think you're just
gonna win but that you're wrong I
thought I knew everything of course and
I thought I was smarter than everyone
else kind of typical sometimes I would
rub people the wrong way and the people
that I would rub the wrong way were
especially people that I third thought
were not squared away in the chain of
command so if you weren't square if you
if you were my boss and I didn't think
you were squared away I was gonna rub
you the wrong way no cuz I was gonna be
slightly offensive yeah as a matter of
fact I got an evaluation it's one of the
first evaluations that I got when I got
to a SEAL team and back in the day yeah
you'd get you were rated 4.0 was the
highest you could get and it would go
all the way down to whatever like one
but at this time basically everyone got
four oh and everything right you
basically got four oh and everything and
like you'd have to mess up you have to
mess to get deviate from the four so I
got all four O's and I got a 3.8 which
was like a major dig and the dig was in
I think it was like in relation like I
don't know what the word was
but when I got debriefed on it what the
guy that gave me the 3/8 what he what he
told me
which I actually was proud of because
that's how stupid I was
he's like you you you're too hostile
with people that aren't squared away
that's literally
and I was all like whatever you're damn
right I am hostile towards people that
aren't square to go to war right just an
idiot
that's what that's what the situation
was and you know it made me mad if a
leader was weak and I would form these
antagonistic relationships with leaders
if I thought that they were weak and one
of these bosses eventually that I fought
I was better than right I thought I was
smarter I thought I was smarter than him
right I thought that he was an idiot
sure I should have his job right how
often do you think that right I should
have that guy's job I'm smart and the
more I showed this attitude the worse
our relationship got in the world and
the less he listened to me and the less
influence I had over how we did things
and therefore the the worse we did and
the and the the worse our ability to
perform God because he was just doing
things the way he thought without any
good input from anyone below him in the
chain of command mm-hmm all because I
had formed this antagonistic
relationship with him which was bad
because then he's not listening to me
and then one day one day I said to
myself if I'm so smart if I'm such a
smart guy why am I losing why am I
losing if I'm so smart if I am so smart
why can't I get this guy to do what I
want him to do even though he's my boss
doesn't matter if I'm so smart yes they
were smarter than him why can't I get
him to do what I wanted me to do hmm
why if I'm so smart how come I can't
have more influence over the way we
operate if I'm so smart and he's so dumb
mm-hmm and that's that's when I realized
that's when I had an away
an awakening that instead of blaming him
for being stupid I was the one who was
being stupid I had lost the ability to
influence my boss because I was being
stupid and because of my ego I literally
thought I deserved his job okay I
thought pretty much anyone could anyone
in the platoon should have his job and
therefore since I thought that I I
understand of supporting him they said a
building a relationship with him i
undermined him now once I got humble and
I started to build a positive
relationship with him instead of an
antagonistic one that started to change
and because because then he started
listening to me he started to change
some things and my influence over the
whole situation became better because I
now had a relationship despite the fact
I liked the guy
despite that fact I built the
relationship and the situation got
better I had more influence and that
became kind of my standard operating
procedure was to build relationships
with people even if I didn't like them
to build relationships with people so
that I could have more influence now
does what does that sound like right
that sounds like I'm kind of this
manipulative two-faced superficial
disingenuous guy yeah that's that's
being devious and conniving not keeping
it real not keeping it real right but
the fact is that is not true that's not
that's not that's not who I am you don't
know who I am I'm a guy that's trying to
accomplish the mission that's what I am
I'm a guy that is trying to accomplish
the mission who is putting my own ego in
check to build a relationship with
someone that I don't like that I don't
respect but what I'm trying to do is
improve our operational capability
what's more important to me trying to
arrange the situation build the
relationship so that we do better not so
that I get promoted not so that I'm
getting some accolades but so that we as
a team do a better job I put the little
feelings aside because I want the team
to win so if you're having having some
trouble getting over your feelings and
getting over your ego to build
relationships for the good of the team
ask yourself the same question I asked
myself a long time ago
which is this if I am so smart why am I
not winning and if you answer that
question honestly then you'll put your
ego in check
you'll go build the relationships that
will make you and your team accomplish
the mission and win hmm there you go
can't help but agree with that one
you know what's funny is if you think
about like why you wouldn't like someone
mm-hmm what what causes you and not like
someone most of the time that's your ego
anyways most of the time that's your ego
anyways yeah and so you know you had
that story of the you know you were
consulting somebody it was like a big
CEO of yeah like a lacrosse guy that
story is probably the most common story
I mean the way you handle it different
yeah but that scenario that you started
with with us are so common man
where ya they rub you the wrong way
because right off the bat you see him as
some kind of competitive figure to you
like they're you know some you know
compare you know you're competing with
them in your own mind in whatever and
the feelings probably meet you a lot of
the time you know see kids don't like
each other you know one anything he says
you're you know you're already defensive
but it's weird man how you can how that
happened like that's happened to me
before not is it wasn't as overt but
just like yeah I don't really feel that
guy you know I don't like I would
because I not only is he like when you
look at them whatever they're kind of
competitive with you but maybe they do
something just this much different than
you you know like it's just different in
philosophy or something like that I was
like oh let me again second and then
they open their mouth and say one word
to you and it's real nice you're like oh
I love that guy you know just one little
thing just one little like hey I'm cool
you know I like you kind of thing and
it's like oh man yeah when they say
something humble to you yeah it disarms
your ego and you're all of a sudden
you're bros yeah it's so weird but if
they don't if they escalate the ego
situation which then it's very
problematic happens all the time I mean
really that's the natural course of
things because you do have to put on the
brakes on your feelings and be like okay
let's make a different kind of decision
than the automatic one I got to switch
to manual real quick and then bling but
the bottom line is you're gonna interact
with all kinds of different people if
you're in any kind of team want so ever
which is most most human beings interact
with other human beings through their
job through their life through I mean
you could apply this to your family too
right
there's someone in your family that you
don't get along with well what good does
it do does it make your family unit
better when you let those emotions play
out and let your ego play out no it
doesn't you're better off you'll get
further and you'll have a better you'll
have a better life in your family if you
put your ego in check and then say you
know what I'm just gonna build a
relationship with this person it's gonna
make everything better and smoother but
it's like man if you it I feel like you
can take the place of any marriage
counselor by just saying that for real
like all you have to do is in and they
got to do it but all you got to do is
ask like is this gonna help the
relationship with my wife or my family
whoever it is in your is this gonna help
the relationship if I do this or don't
do this or is it gonna hurt it and
that's it that's it that's super general
question or whatever but it's it's so
cut and dry most of the time yeah of
course it's exceptions but generally
speaking it's pretty cut and dry okay
and a lot of time just like I said it
has to do with like your ego or your you
know this this sense of vengeance little
micro sense of vengeance because I can't
believe she doesn't respect the fact
that I took out the trash you know she
asked me to take the trash all the time
finally when I do it nothing you know
like chilli its I was talking to a
friend of mine and we were talking about
you know I've talked about the mutiny
that I had yeah yeah
Co platoon but we had a mutiny we fight
we had a mutiny against uh our platoon
commander we fired he got fired and then
the other guy that came in to take his
place was like the best guy mm-hmm and I
was talking to a guy that worked with
him much later when he was a senior
senior guy and I was telling him I was
like oh when I talk on the podcast about
the platoon commander that was like the
best that's who I'm talking he's like no
way and and this guy working with he's a
senior guy and he says you know when he
when I worked with him he would take out
that he would take out the trash from
the office every day and he and I
started laughing said that's right and
I'd be look and he was saying like oh I
look at him and be like sir you know you
don't need to do that it's like no no
it's not good you know someone's got to
take out the trash I got it mm-hmm
this is a seat a guy that shouldn't have
been taking out trash for 25 years
taking out the trash
well is he picking up breath picking up
brass taking out trash you know that's
that's being humble yeah being humble
goes a long way